au milieu de débris encore fumants
ces secouristes s'activent pour tenter
de retrouver des survivants
quelques mètres plus loin plusieurs
corps sans vie viennent d'être extrait
des décombres
la frappe russe qui s'est abattue dans
la nuit de dimanche à lundi sur ce
centre commercial de piaf a été très
puissante
d'abord j'ai entendu une énorme
explosion puis un flash a illuminé ma
chambre je vis juste ici devant
l'explosion était si forte qu'elle m'a
propulsé hors de mon bras
le centre commercial a été en partie
pulvérisé et avec lui c'est un lieu
majeur d'approvisionnement pour les
habitants qui est parti en fumée selon
le maire de la ville vitali klischko
plusieurs immeubles résidentiels ainsi
que des écoles et des crèches ont
également été endommagées
des dégâts visibles aux premières heures
du jour
cet aumônier de l'armée ukrainienne se
dit sidéré par tant de violence
les rues sont épuisés mais limite
d'amour les troupes russes tentent
toujours de son pari de la capitale
c'est même leur principal objectif selon
les services de renseignement
britanniques
mais sur le terrain autour de kiev il se
heurte à une importante résistance
ukrainienne la capitale sera de nouveau
soumise à un couvre-feu à partir de ce
lundi soir